a trooper in Utah rushed into harm's way
to save a man's life with just seconds
to spare
dramatic dashcam video shows trooper
Ruben Correa running toward a car
stranded on railroad tracks
he then scrambles to pull out the driver
who is unconscious just as a train
barrels toward them our lead national
correspondent David Begg know is here
with the incredible rescue David how did
the man get stuck a good news story of
the morning Anthony turns out he had a
medical emergency loses control of his
vehicle crashes through a fence and
winds up stuck on the tracks the trooper
is nearby on another call he gets the
call to head to the scene and watch what
happens it was just after 650 a.m.
Wednesday morning Highway Patrol trooper
Ruben Correa pulled up to the scene
where the SUV was stuck on the railroad
tracks that train was coming pretty fast
so at that point I actually wasn't
really thinking I was just doing my job
and the main concern was getting him out
he ran toward the SUV with his
flashlight on believing the driver was
still inside he would have just 35
seconds to get the man out
he did it with less than two seconds to
spare
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the car flew through the air as the
Train bulldoze down the track I got
worried after I saw the the train hit
the hit the vehicle in the vehicle flew
about thirty feet in front of us and
that's when I realized oh wow when I was
I was a lot closer than what I would
have liked that was the aftermath the
driver told the state trooper he is just
grateful to be alive I'm still trying to
process everything that happened I'm
just very grateful that I was able to
get him out and he's alive and he's back
with his family now the trooper has only
been on the force for about a year and a
half the driver told the State Police he
is okay he's in his 20s and he said I
don't want to talk to the media don't
worry named and you know what that is
okay how about this trooper yeah that
little flashlight and a big light coming
from the big train yeah really amazing
yeah and even though David we know how
the story is going to end that there's a
happy ending it still is tough to watch
it what you call a close call I mean you
could see that light coming yeah
grabbing the guy in oh I could see why
the guy doesn't want to be named well I
want to talk about trooper career good
news